now for a trip inside trump world's hall
of mirrors
[Music]
sorry i said i wasn't gonna do this
jesus this has never been about
collusion
what is the matter with you
this is a lie again they're saying
breaking news
it's illegal to possess these stolen
documents
you are fake news sir don't believe them
oh no that sucks louder with crowder
studios
protected exclusively by walter and
[Music]
betty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anxious mindy late night host slowly
losing her mind without the sounds of
laughter and applause
now i think my patience is
slowly
[Music]
[Music]
it's not easy to
afraid it could rub off on me
[Applause]
is
is
counties that are majority black have
three times the rate of infections the
answer to all cuomo's questions is
tragically familiar
centuries of racism all right i'm going
to do some jokes so excited to be doing
the show from my panic room i mean
living room
doing the show for my home for two
reasons first to stop the spread of the
coronavirus
second so i could write off my real
estate tax that's our monologue
everybody
trump wants every single one of these
checks to have his signature on them
which would be the first time he's ever
put his name
on something helpful dumbest thing he's
decided to put his name on something
really dumb brilliant do you ever think
about calling
trump and suggesting ways that he could
he could do better
never allowed any crisis from the civil
war straight through to
that pandemic is 17 all the way around
16. we have never
never let our democracy
second base
i've never just told jokes to myself
i'm not even trying to be funny here's
no
[Music]
that's joke easy to warm
[Music]
[Music]
you're that's what i
[Music]
know
and that's called the late night
expecting a joke and instead it's a
webcam video oh
everybody see that it's the old ollie
shuffle whoa whoa maybe funny
no
[Laughter]
we have uh senator ted cruz in the show
wow right here of course is the winner
for the stimulus uh stimulus funding
1200 really yep i'm gonna read that a
little bit later on
uh everybody here you guys all have
gotten your checks
no you absolutely have you know the
problem
you are being paid more now than ever
yeah that's true right
because we're still working yes well
that's good right yeah i think
well anyway this guy's going to
appreciate it oh yeah
tomorrow morning of course we have good
morning mug clubs and this is uh mug
club quarantine the month uh we have dan
crenshaw on the show
that's huge that bastard he bumped us he
didn't show up on wednesday so we'll
have him tomorrow the promo code is
quarantined
you get thirty dollars off through the
whole month of april
people are saying what if they extend
the quarantine and my municipality
listen
it's not a regional promotion yeah
so i'm gonna be on a national level guys
come on sorry kent
county but you get the same rules as
everyone else
and uh of course uh we're uh we're
broadcasting twice a day every day yeah
and i am very tired so
we have my half asian lawyer bill
richmond is here how are you saying hey
he's lost 12 pounds
yes that's good for him thank you i mean
that's uh that's like a
free that's like a twin i know it's
amazing quarter black garrett is here
what's up i'm glad that you i'm glad you
stuck your perfectly straight hair back
underneath the baseball cap so that you
can pass this
facial as opposed to 90s bully uh audio
weight is here
g morgan junior gerald a what's the one
of the day one of the day is cosmic egg
the cosmic egg psychedelic cosmic monkey
i don't like why do we have brian
stelter's head as a wine i
it does look like that doesn't it it
doesn't look like that at all
weak there um so i was throwing him a
bone we're going to be talking about
trevor noah
late night all of this so my question
for you i guess is what's your
opinion been of of late night during
this pandemic kimmel colbert
myers which one do you think has done it
best
is there even a joke or a bit that
stands out i gotta tell you
i feel really good about it because for
the first time they've entered into our
arena
and they suck and they definitely suck i
used to think they were worthy
competitors
now just unworthy
and we'll be getting to uh of course the
denigrating of all the american
the american citizens who think they
should be getting back to work and
trevor noah decided to take a big
steaming south africa
crap on them ship them out uh but first
first we're all tied up in our national
news it's important to look
to international it is politics uh to
learn that you know what
you can still die with dignity
[Music]
is uganda's bill murray equivalent in
get low or he's an ass
actually people took liberties with his
funeral actually in their culture death
is good really ah yes because it's a
sweet release from life
exactly like one of my favorites where
is that option on the funeral home
would you like the hype crew to carry
your castle sometimes i feel that way
about this
show i want that yeah can i have how do
i order what do you want
you want to be a black man with uh
peanuts i don't know who was in that
that could have been me in there dancing
that's the best dancing i've ever seen
it's like looking into a mirror
[Laughter]
uh you're the one who's supposed to
prevent us from getting my hand on yes
i'm praising the dancing feeling we have
some news to get yeah it's it's the
threat
it's the racism of soft expectations
bill i know i know they're not all
necessarily doing little rascals on each
other's shoulders with a dragon going
like this
i grew up baptist i love dancing in any
form do you really
yeah how many words for snow do you have
um well my people have 97 words for snow
land bridge theory it checks out so
news uh before we move on coven 19 of
course this is what everyone's
talking about and covet 19 has changed a
lot of people's minds
uh it's actually forced epidemiologists
to question the long-standing medical
theory that
quote laughter is the best medicine
yeah so
reverse course on that it's uh no secret
of course that donald trump has been
holding daily press briefings we did a
live streaming with one of those
which networks have accused of turning
into propaganda sessions
with cnn even going uh so far as to
refuse to even air them
replacing it instead with a fat gay guy
talking about them
so they yeah you know serving you just
the facts
brian stelter this week stated and i
want to make sure i get this right
that it's quote okay to not be okay
this week when he was speaking of his
grief over the coronavirus
even leading to his admission that he
crawled
into bed and cried for hours over the
pandemic
and matters just weren't helped any when
his tweet was protested by the westboro
baptist church
so that's a double oh yeah it's too bad
for him yeah that's a double whammy it's
tough when you get in their sights
i don't know if delta was expecting some
empathy from this side of the peanut
gallery
[Laughter]
sorry mistake he wouldn't cried with his
millions of dollars don't worry he's
okay
uh switching to international news back
to international news because that's
bill's forte apparently i love it
uh international a kenyan governor
announced plans to include
hennessy in coronavirus care packages
this week
i like this guy yes he claimed that
quote alcohol plays a very major role in
killing the coronavirus or any sort of
virus that's his quote not ours don't
don't snope us um now of course kenyan
governor mike sanko
he's not to be confused with nigerian
president muhammadu buhari who himself
is a
notorious cult 45 man
i mean you wouldn't expect that would
you i mean it's like richmond i mean
you know it doesn't make sense we are
very proud of our leadership he has done
a fantastic
job in leading our people to prosperity
right
mike back at you
uh back to america of course joe biden
has been um
it's not really a laughing matter he's
been showing troubling signs of early
onset
dementia which has led many experts to
question the capability of his basic
memory so
one thing he'll never forget sniffing
shirley temple
oh my gosh how does he
not even going to say it i can't you'd
remember it from that
favorite joke i've ever ever written in
my life
because not only is he a pedophile not
only in that joke is joe biden very old
yeah
he's old enough to have been a pedophile
when he sniffed shirley temple ah
yeah and if you don't appreciate that go
watch trevor
in an odd turn eventually today is
shirley temple's birthday really yeah
joe knows
don't over complicate the jokes um
also uh this is other news uh new york
city mayor for those who are bill de
blasio oh yeah right here a lot of
people forget because there are so many
notable mayors of new york
not him and then this guy yeah uh
his social distancing tip line was
flooded by the way with um
warning if you have kids in their penis
photos and hitler memes so
funny yeah let me explain the story of
this
new yorkers show de blasio how they felt
about being
asked to snitch on each other when yes
zipline went public by flooding it
with crank complaints including pictures
of penises and memes featuring adolf
hitler now i do want to note that
the photos were initially separate until
the great meme convergence of hitler
pick and that became a problem oh
no took it too far yeah that is
for raging pinocchios
and all of a sudden anthony weiner is
back in the news he is always back
is he president yet i mean i feel he
should be he should be yeah something to
do while his wife is off on her secret
lesbian escapades
so um in religion news
secret pope francis uh he said that
whiskey is
uh real holy water in a censored clip
all these guys
yeah the clip was actually uh the clip
was set to debut in an upcoming
documentary
but it was censored by the vatican over
concerns for
the pope's image and i i mean i
understand they have to do damage
control
this should come as no surprise from the
man who once saw mary in his crack rock
so really he has a long man this is a
partier
that is a large crack rocker he is that
one part of a productive pope
yeah you're more productive just cleaned
the whole vatican for hours
yeah i love it i love how we're crushing
it made his own shoes
what's that 24 karat i want to see my
face in it best and smartest guy
especially when it comes to mass monday
is the one who is instantly identifying
the absurd size of the crack rock
yeah yeah i know it's insulted no no
look at this one what yeah
it should be a mass crack day
because you do so much crack cocaine i
was picking up i'm joking he's a meth
guy
i have all my teeth can't afford crack
but give him some antifreeze and a
couple bottles of
nails and he's good to go
they sell nails in bottles that's how
that shows you how
are you okay last time i went to a
lowe's right
yeah hey do you have any uh how do you
have nails i don't know i don't depends
how much do you need
like a bottle i mean you got to pour
them out right you got a bottle of nails
preferably with a funnel included uh i
love how all of our contractor friends
are like
what in them right now no no they're
going
what is he saying so ouch come on what
do you mean they're watching this in
their iphone on the back of a pickup
truck now we turn
to the latest of course with uh
coronavirus kobit 19 whose
rapid spread has changed the way that we
now look at the disease there's been
some there's been some new updates this
week we've talked about them quite a bit
in the morning show
um a little more laid back we get into
the ins and outs of death rates so
now understanding now that the vast
majority of people who contract the
disease are asymptomatic we're learning
this
this means that while the mortality rate
is drastically lower
than initially expected and that's a
good thing more people can be potential
carriers
so you win some you lose some unless
you're the detroit lions
hmm yeah then you just lose something
right a lot i wasn't expecting that one
so finally last week dozens of
celebrities
uh teamed up i thought i thought you
were going to say bernie i decided that
i don't care anymore
you guys go along with it
you don't have to show up heavy is the
heavy where's the crown heavy is the
head
that wears the crown i have a big head i
have a famous guy head i'm just not that
famous
so it just comes with all sort of
cranial complications
without the benefit of a multi-million
dollar contract none of them uh finally
i think
was it last week yeah dozens of
celebrities they teamed up for an
eight-hour stream called
one world and by the way whenever one
world is in the
you know it's going to be crap from a
saturday morning show after hang time
and city guys
anyone out there who remembers it you
know what i'm talking about there's one
asian actor in there sorry
i'd represent your people well i look
from that all
you know whatever it is this thing right
here it's called one world together at
home
um one of the standout performances of
course was this went viral was from the
rolling stones
keith richards huh he's basically been
embalmed
yeah i don't know how he does not their
best he's never been sober
and it works for him yeah who's going to
tell him who's going to tell keith
richards to sober up
yeah yeah he's just being preserved by
god king tut plays the
he's well pickled okay come on think
about your family you think about your
family yeah
it would just never it wouldn't tell me
huh what am i doing wrong
i'm just sitting here i'll be playing
the maracas making millions
who cares if i look like captain jack
sparrow it works
oh my gosh from liver from liverpool i
don't think that's that i don't think
that's regionally accurate
uh now of course there were a lot of
people they spec they were talking about
how you hear
in there there's a shaker yeah i heard
it but the person who was using the
shaker wasn't pictured
oh and so this became it became a sort
of a phenomenon online people were
had conspiracies who was doing this here
at the letter with credit program we
have an exclusive
footage uh that's been made available to
us of the mysterious shaker player
since we couldn't afford the rights
though to be clear you'll be happy with
this half-fish but we couldn't afford
the rights of the rolling stones song
we didn't want to run a file of the
copyright so here is the isolated track
hey man are you getting camera it's not
showing up on zoom
you have to take advantage of the scoop
yeah well that's the problem with zoom
the unmute he just
he did it i don't know anything about
that's zoom humor yeah
it's not my genre of humor i don't even
know if it's humor i would your humor
your
genre your wheelhouse is zoom in crack
rocks crack rocks that are oversized
look at them zoom in through the rest uh
hey
quarterback here what are the tweets of
the week that we have up here we got a
bunch of tweets uh
new club members they got their mugs
within five days
oh wow that's awesome that's pretty
awesome thank you so much for sending
black rifle coffee in there
yeah yes much like breakfast i noticed
people really like the dark roast from
black rifle
which is uh you know i it's i'm not a
big fan of dark roast i'm a fan of the
medium roast this is one but you know if
that's if
it's your thing is that your favorite
from the medium
you said you like called there are
multiple medium medium kind of roast
well i feel like it'd be
yes thank you for picking a color
knowing i couldn't see it
well how are you that brings a lot of
things together
what do you have that goes well with a
nice with a nice fillet
oh i don't know you could write yourself
a nice white or
green let's let's stick with the white
why don't you just tell me the name of
the wine you would like sir
this is this that this i believe is uh
is speckled that champagne it is
it's champagne yeah um the winner
by the way you will be receiving twelve
hundred dollars wow because i don't need
the stimulus check and uh we're able to
keep our jobs here i know that many of
you have been uh affected it is
uh what's his name it's oh my goodness
father to ellie west
nice father to ellie west edgar all
right
i don't know i hope i didn't hope i
didn't talk to you that sounds like a
long name
and doxxing would be the least of your
worries uh
here we have it for me says he's a 25
year old driver for trucking company
he's gone away for weeks at a time uh
here's why i am asking for a blessing
starting february 2019 my wonderful wife
found out she's three weeks pregnant
with her beautiful baby boy
congratulations
not even three days after finding out
the news her health went down
she's in bed rest as of right now uh
he's the only
income for them so uh man you know what
i know a lot of people have been
affected if i
had the money i would give twelve
hundred dollars away to everybody but
you know what you guys should hit up
trevor noah because he wants to give
back
you know well yang is generous yeah with
my money with your money yeah yeah right
he'll take it from you and give it like
when you leave i serve your wine up
to everyone else oh the difference is i
know which color it is
which one i'm do do you understand that
you understand how color works
i i think he's like covering it up like
it's glass
it's see-through it's translucent i can
still see
now you're just clutching it like a baby
because it's your unhealthy addiction
everything you do makes things worse in
this room i i should sit still
i love you
[Laughter]
i see that i saw it no i really do you
were great too but thank you for
flying co-pilot in the uh yeah live
stream by the way we are doing a live
stream next thursday where we will be
doing another press briefing we'll be
doing exactly
and then continuing uh through cnn prime
time
fact checking them since they won't run
the press briefings i believe that
who do we have we have chris cuomo we
have wolf blitzer oh jeez aaron burnett
the whole rose gallery yeah because a
lot of you gave us some positive
feedback that you liked the press
briefing and you want us to do more of
it and we thought well you know what
though
then the next day we were sort of
covering the lies that happened after
the press briefing and since we won't be
doing a show next friday since that's
the end of mud club quarantine we just
said let's just do
four hours because i'm a sadomasochist
you are that's true nothing like
finishing strong
yeah well let's go with that um
so trip i want to talk trevor noah uh a
lot of people have been making these
same exact claims out there where
they've just been
vilifying anyone who wants to go back to
work as conspiracy theory
nuts as morons as flyover dunces so
let's specifically just target trevor
noah because i think he's everything
wrong
with not america because he's not from
here and he shouldn't be here just
humanity
yeah emblematic i don't know how that
guy got a visa
was the hb1 for highly skilled workers
no no no no
no no do you have any somehow he got in
sir somehow
someone tricked the tax man into
thinking trevor noah is a highly skilled
worker
never saw letterman i'm guessing i think
he also tricked people into thinking he
was funny too
well that was the implication yeah so
way to lay it out there joe
yeah well just in case somebody misses
it so here's the context i want to run
some clips and we'll go through
he's just emblematic of this so it's
perfect because we can rebut all of his
points because it kind of just
it's this amalgamate of horrible points
and straw men that everyone else
uh has been making uh here's a clip i
think with the first clip
he's vilifying the protesters and right
here this is the same attack you hear
all the time
that people who are protesting out there
right now who want to restart the
economy
uh they clearly want to increase deaths
over the weekend america surpassed 40
000 confirmed coronavirus deaths
and 750 000 confirmed infections
and because of that most of us have
accepted that as painful as it is
we need to stay at home a little longer
until we can get those numbers under
control
but it turns out there's a different
group of people around the country who
are saying
nah how can we get those numbers he's
wearing a sweater that makes him look
like he's protesting coast to coast
with calls to thousands lining the
streets of wisconsin
rallying cries from washington to
colorado to maryland
actually people just want it first off
it's just so bad
if you add if you make that if you make
that hood pink that's justin trudeau
and his little edmond done like an
uncircumcised
trevor noah oh oh yeah i guess if
there's like some penicillin on the
oh the point but here's the thing i got
a vision in my head it is remarkable to
me
that we vilify these people who want
they want to go back to work by the way
and
now we're seeing the numbers increased
suicides increased anxiety
depression uh why do you want more
people to die by locking them at home
yeah this is something important to know
22 million americans filed jobless
claims wow
surveys have uh showed that one in four
americans have either lost their job
or had pay cut from shutdowns yet most
businesses they don't even know how much
this is going to last i think it was 35
percent of retailers that were
non-groceries
20 something percent of hotels 15 to 20
of restaurants they say they'll have to
close if the crisis continues
over the coming months and we know that
that kind of stress and trauma
comes with suicide depression okay that
is more of a burden on her health system
than building extra hospitals that are
entirely empty yeah and people are
picking on other states for opening up
saying look you don't need to get your
hair cut you don't need to go to a nail
salon right and that's not that's not
really the point it's emblematic of the
whole shutdown it's like
we need to be able to go out and do
things that are safe enough to do don't
just pick
the hair salons and the nail salons
right tattoo parlors and say we can't do
that
we can go out and shop six feet away if
home depot can be open nebraska
furniture mart can be up
trevor trevor noah's perm guy is he come
he does house calls
oh well that's convenient from six feet
away
today it's like he's dead he's just like
we're not even alive today i don't know
what happened
insulted my people hold on i'm just
counting all the money i'm gonna make
from legal fees
and you're getting sued over these jokes
right i love it i love it
come at me trevor noah um come at me
bruh
no no no no he won't he won't he's very
small and um unfunny so wispy
really wispy wispy very good he has a
mustache like the taco bell dog yeah
oh yeah yeah he has a mustache like
amber
heard should beat the [ __ ] out of him so
too close domestic abuse joke it's funny
when it happens to men
it is you can't joke about rape ever
unless it's about men
then it's a good time for all um here's
something else that he talks about here
he has this misconception about
flattening the curve and have you
noticed by the way we were always
talking about flattening the curve that
was the whole thing it was the whole
thing
you're not hearing that nearly as much
now it's flattening the curve flatten
the curve you've got to flatten the
curve you've got to flatten the curve
you've got a flat in the curve that's
always what we've thing flattening the
curve people need to understand this
okay it's not too you can't eliminate
the disease by flattening the curve it
was to manage the cases in a way so that
the healthcare system
wasn't overloaded right here's the
graphic that i think that we always yeah
we would always see yeah
and i get it like you just look at the
graph it doesn't really mean anything
you can look into the numbers
because you can make a graph look like
anything but that was the idea you want
to fly and that's a legitimate thing to
do
i want to make this very clear that we
should do that we
absolutely did do that by the way okay
this is why they said we need forty
thousand uh
ventilators and turned out they didn't
even need four thousand right right they
opened up these new hospitals and now
they're shutting them down
they're laying off or furloughing
healthcare workers because we have not
seen this influx of people remember
early on they said hey
if you think you have symptoms and
you're young stay home don't overload
the hospital right
now at huffpo and cnn they're saying
young people are waiting too long before
they flood hospitals
yeah they were converting stadiums into
hospitals they were building hospitals
in central park they were doing
all these field hospitals and they're
like oh hell we built those and now we
don't need it it's uh
we don't need any of that and by the way
just something to be clear flattening
the curve
is important so that you obviously give
it's that rubber band effect that you
give the healthcare system enough time
to deal with the burden but as far as
the disease flattening the curve
does can often just make it go longer
you need to be clear about it by
definition
yeah it makes it go longer it makes i
was trying to hedge my words because my
lawyer was in the room
yeah so go ahead and you can say it
definitely well look i mean
whenever you look at every single
graphic of flattening the curve they're
saying
stretch it out as long as possible again
to not overload
yes just like gak just like a crappy
play-doh that your mom made at home
because she wouldn't get you the real
stuff
i don't even know it really wasn't full
of about the stretch armstrong because
my
but then the question goes can you see
how red my face is look at him
oh no that's right he looks like an
asian i'm sorry i interrupted your point
you're the
shades of white no i am second smartest
of gerald hey you missed
um is you're going to keep dragging it
out drag it out to win until when to win
november december
2025. i mean that's the issue there's no
you know the folks we go back to like
rachel maddow you pointed out last week
is saying
we can't even think about reopening oh
we're just supposed to really not think
about saving jobs right about opening up
the economy about allowing people to
support themselves
who's going to pay rent in november if
we're still shut down oh
aoc hasn't just just don't pay rent yeah
what if i but what if i what if i have a
more just don't pay but what about the
guy who needs you to pay so that he can
pay well he doesn't have to pay
where does it go and well just more debt
from china you don't understand how this
works
you bug-eyed bug no no you know she
knows
that could you she knows hey
ao pug definitely knows this is one step
closer she reminds me of like a of like
a
like a sort of milky brown version of
star jones after she lost
the weight and you're like ooh put it
back on
that face wasn't built for that box yeah
some people some people like to lose
weight and they're looking great like
bill with 12 pounds yeah looks good
and then there's some people like al
roker where they just look like they
once upon a time were wearing a fat suit
yeah
it's like an edgar suit yeah like unzip
hey
val kilmer what i don't know you were in
there
such a good one for you al roker so um
what's happening in your neck of the
woods which neck
as long here's the thing as long as our
health care systems are not overwhelmed
flattening the curve beyond what we have
done uh
it's not going to save lives it is it's
likely the same amount of people who
will die
during the total duration of the disease
right that's important so
this begs the question this is important
like you just brought up if
hospitals are not overburdened and if
you're watching cnn you may not know
this objectively they are not
they're not they've built new hospitals
i don't know that any single new
hospital has had to be used
i know that the vast majority of them
we've reported on this in the morning
are empty and they're shutting them down
right i don't know if there's a single
one there prob there probably could be
but i don't know most hospitals extra
hospitals are not being used at all they
are not the hospitals that we currently
have are not
at capacity or over capacity so it begs
this question if hospitals are not
overburdened which was the goal of
flattening the curve that means we've
done it
what is the goal of a continued
indefinite shutdown
you started this with we've got to
flatten the curve okay we've done it
and now you want to excoriate anyone who
says all right we've done it time to get
back to work
why i don't have and i know i'm doing a
little bit of a jesse ventura right now
who might join the green party which
please
[Laughter]
i know i'm just saying like i'm just
asking questions but i'll give you the
answer
because they want this to drag on
indefinitely here's the thing right now
if we start the economy back up when we
get back to the best economy that we've
ever had guess what people are going to
remember
this oh yeah absolutely initially they
wanted you remember this in november
so do i now they want you to still be
in this come november because there's no
objective reason
to try and flatten the curve when it's
already been done there's no objective
reason for an indefinite
shutdown it's abs and by the way europe
many places in europe they're far more
leftist they don't have
conservatives no they have liberals and
liberal separatists and communists
and they're like we're gonna shut down
our economy forever that's ridiculous
yeah that's a that's a really terrible
idea and this is a classic some are the
swedish chefs
[Laughter]
this is a classic example of the
treatment killing the patient so the
whole goal was to save the hospital
system essentially right
don't overwhelm it so that it ends up
collapsing right now what they've done
is they've taken away the main source of
income which is elected procedures
and now hospitals stop looking down stop
looking down at you
it moved i'm sorry something moves
because you're not supposed to be
looking at so what's happening
gerald writes a note down there are i am
there are two words
and you're looking down like you can't
remember what you're about to say it's
like
a t-rex i just realized movement-based
gerald's notes
right we don't really have it we don't
really use prompter here but we have
some notes that we just scribble and we
put on an ipad and
just to make sure we don't inside
baseball make sure that everyone
remembers their points
they're color-coded i [ __ ] you without
even meaning to
oh my gosh it's just i just randomly
hope that it
i know i don't realize until just now
that gerald's points
are color-coded it's okay
[Laughter]
i don't think they used to only be color
i swear to god they used to only be
color coded and then i really like huh
gerald puts in like it's just a weird
like if ever you could see the
show map it says like clip b trevor noah
says that's all we're going but yeah but
then i thought it was weird that
it was blue like okay so blue is
gerald's color and then he started
adding gm
colon he forgets his name
i just wow i just realized that's
because he's colorblind he's working off
them shakespeare
i feel horrible you should you should i
don't but i love you
and that now i understand anyway right
no it is don't look down it is moving
away
something moved and i looked out sorry
so but it's not a t-rex
i've made that joke five minutes you get
your own sticky notes all right so what
the the back to the point was that we
are going to do the same thing that we
were trying to avoid in the first place
and kill the economy at the same time
right and we're gonna make the hospitals
close down because they don't have
enough money to keep the staff on
anymore
yeah right they have to open back up
they absolutely have to or they will be
gone
of course they're they're they're saying
they need to open back up now like we
should start doing some
you know like a knee surgery yeah so our
whole point to save the hospital is
killing the hospital yeah
and the next point here that we uh we
have from trevor noah is he makes this
claim you hear this a whole bunch
this idea that people are out there the
more you protest right
all of you protest is out there i don't
know i can't do the accident
it doesn't i've known a lot of south
africans they don't sound like him no
it's hard to do accents
you've got to add that layer of
difficulty yeah
hard you know it's easy if you're doing
like a mickey rooney breakfast at
tiffany's you're right like
but just like ah how do i convey unfunny
yeah it's tough but with an
international vine oh no no no
um i bet you he was probably raised in
like west mount i get to
the guys so uh
this is the point that the more that you
protest right the longer we're going to
have to lock down
all around the country over the weekend
protests birthing sweater
demanding an immediate end to lockdowns
and let's be honest people this is both
insane
and counterproductive because the more
you gather in groups
the longer the lockdown will have to go
on can you imagine if during the aids
crisis
mobs of people gather to gang bang that
monkey that started it all
what do we want monkey sex when do we
want it
now okay i don't know i just
i only i only the problem i still have
an injured foot and it's gonna be very
difficult for me to
to finger with my toe the trigger to the
shotgun in my mouth
yeah it'll be difficult it is so
painfully unfunny
that my back hurts right now watching
that couple of reasons let me let me
give you why this is first off it's 2009
youtube crap right
where someone is doing the whole like
hey and i we used to do this back like
philip defranco would do it like you you
would
kind of do a character in his case a
straw man right you could do a character
maybe you'd put on like if you're shane
dawson you'd go on blackface by slapping
putting on your face to be
corbin blue and then hope people forget
about it but the point is you would do
that and then go back to commentary
but the issue here is uh he's batted it
it's straw manning it's not funny
and this is something we've talked about
uh quarter black garrett he's not he's
not projecting to the audience he's
playing to the room and so
we've had this yeah remember when we
were in green screens every time we've
performed sometimes we've been doing
like
saving private ryan and people be
sitting there going talking hey captain
like this whispering i'm going listen
i know we're in a small room with a
green screen but picture yourself being
on the battlefield
so if trevor noah were a professional
performer with any experience let me
explain to you why that's awkward
sure he's unfunny to begin with right
but
he what do we want no that should be
back off from the microphone
what do we want yelling like you would
be outside at a protest give it some
passion then it doesn't feel so awkward
with people wanting to punch you in the
face and it's not because you're south
african it's just because you're bad at
your job
it remains unfunny though even if it's
louder no yeah all of those it would at
least be done well at least it would
have some enthusiasm
so and here's the truth of the matter
here is that uh yeah okay obviously
there have been some dumb protesters
but a lot of these protests people are
staying in their cars with plenty of
space in between and i've seen people in
their cars
with masks which i we encouraged masks
back when the cdc was saying don't wear
masks because
i think that you should be wearing masks
so protest when you're destroying public
property good
yeah right that's now bad yeah now and i
will say you should wear a mask i think
we should destigmatize masks in public
but if you're wearing a mask in your car
you're a pretty so and an idiot
yeah yeah well that too yeah i saw a guy
with a mask on i swear
i drove up next to him he had a mask and
he did everything wrong he grabbed it
from the middle grabbed it from the
middle
pulled it down and vaped
[Laughter]
just doing my part so
it was the pose it was the post oh it
wasn't a vape so
no one talks about i haven't seen this
on many other shows or any other shows
uh we're talking about people being in
their cars for example in lansing cap
right
let's take even more extreme some people
on the beach who are maybe not exactly
six feet apart
out in the uv light with the salt water
right you know
that's something that we need to be
upset about people in parks who are
distance
none of it compares to the people in new
york who are in the subways
every day they've never been closed they
have
never been closed in israel why aren't
we bitching about that and i i
understand this because when you live in
a big city
you can't be independent you can't get
in your car and drive anywhere i i used
to think new york was a living hell
when i was there because i had to get on
the subway i was on the east side where
i had to take the green line and at that
point
they were talking about how they were
going to build another one i think on uh
well then where were they going to build
another one
it might have been on second they never
did they never did it was a project that
has been going on for 30 years i think
they built it now and i would have three
subways go by that were full
where i couldn't get on to wait for the
next one in new york
this is i can't find me a place more
contaminated
than the l train right have you seen the
warriors
do you know how many kovid strains
you've catched just bopping your way to
kony to avoid the baseball furies okay
anyway i just i'm amazed that no one's
talking about well and it's subways more
and i hate subway so any chance i can
yeah well you shouldn't be able to but
that would be the only fair thing to do
right you have to have some kind of
media coverage saying if somebody's in a
car in michigan
it's really just pointing out that
they're doing it to people that they
like right democratic governors are
facing these protests that's
what they're trying to protect against
uh here's another claim that he made and
you've heard this quite a bit and this
is not new but trevor noah makes it
because he doesn't really have he
doesn't have a sense for originality he
doesn't even enter into the equation
that the protests are of course far
right and uh some are anti-semitic or
something
now these protests have clearly been
infused with the far-right ideology
clearly
many demonstrators wore maga hats they
held up anti-semitic signs
and in michigan they even waved
confederate flags
a clear symbol of michigan's proud
southern heritage
all right that last one was a little
funny i'll give you that but let's be
really clear
the sign that said hail whitmer that's
not anti-semitic it's comparing governor
whitmer
to hitler which i would not personally
do
they're trying to imply that her her
orders are fascists you know like
they do with trump all the time and most
importantly it's a pun
that works you should take notes they
should give you a weekend
course trevor noah i do get up there
he doesn't understand like hell with
jokes oh is he you support the ss
no he just likes jokes you
i do like it just completely
unironically is talking about how
comparing someone who engages in
wrongful government tyranny
as a bad person is somehow against
the jews right like some yeah i mean
but there's no correction i mean but
that is the thing he's not the only one
first they came to protect the jews
and then there was no one left to
protect me that's not the quote the
quota they came and you said nothing
these people are saying something that's
exactly so bad
no that's a good point obviously i think
we're going to go the direction of south
africa because government tyranny
well yeah that too uh
he's from not really south africa that's
true i don't even know where wes but
westbound is an area in montreal oh i
just threw it out there
i just used words it sounded nice and
also you maybe you may be knowing i know
some people out there saying well what
about the swastika that i saw at these
protests
yeah well uh turns out that was actually
an antifa supporter pretending to be a
trump supporter and
it wasn't even a lockdown protest at all
it was at a bernie rally so
there is that yeah and it's pretty cheap
to define a movement but even if any of
these claims were true which or not it's
pretty cheap to define a movement by a
few bad apples every
every movement like this every protest
every rally is going to potentially have
an idiot that shows up and we can all
point at them and say yeah they're
idiots
that doesn't mean that every other
person that was there trying to make
sure they can put food on the table
should be lumped in with that person
right right and that's exactly what he's
doing with all of this
yeah it's remarkable i mean every job is
essential to the people who rely on it
too yeah i can't feed your family living
it is remarkable to me like hey let me
ask you out there folks who you know
work okay are there still those people
out for you at all is it essential for
you
to you know make a living yeah just you
tell me i don't know
we'll put a poll on twitter we'll see
what the answer is i have no idea we'll
see if that's a normal part of life yeah
i'm not gonna lie that paul will have
incredibly redundant answers
it's going to be pretty uh by the way if
you haven't joined mud club yet of
course please do use the quarantine
promo code promo code quarantine you get
30 off that's why we're doing this
monthly
quarantine month at lighthousepatter.com
mug club and if you're subscribed on
youtube you're not convinced to join my
club yet just hit notification bell
hit all notifications so that that way
you uh you find out about uh our videos
but you know what it's also not that
hard
weeknights every night at eight right
there you go then good morning
one more congratulations i saved you the
horror of having to
[Laughter]
i'm angry today because i had to spend
all morning watching trevor noah
well what were you about to say
sometimes i say podcast i actually have
been listening
that's a lot more so for the episodes
that i'm not on i listen to it
so i'm out there while i'm being forced
to do work if you don't want to see my
face
podcast is a good good way to go yeah
yeah gerald did you hear that i actually
listened to the show
oh is that required on the job yeah
cause he walks in so what are we talking
about today
okay here's another claim that he makes
from trevor noah is that reopening the
economy is anti-science
why because something something
something unfunny something dr fauci
you see after dr fauci appeared on the
network and made the case for continuing
the shutdowns
fox news decided to get a second opinion
it's like a malcolm in the middle
transition
everyone can trust talk show host dr
phil mcgraw appearing on fox news
blasting the government's response
appearing to downplay the pandemic okay
uh listen dr phil is not the voice of
these protesters
far be it from me to defend dr phil
that being said the plan and this is why
they don't run the press briefings this
is why we did the press briefing live
stream and we will do it next thursday
donald trump's plan for reopening the
economy it's been created
developed very carefully with a team of
doctors
pretending that it's just all right open
for the flood that's not what he's
planning
you're talking about a multi-phase
system that still involves
mainly social distancing and protecting
our most vulnerable all the way until
phase three if i'm not mistaken they're
going to be adding more phases which is
a little bit ridiculous to me
not that we shouldn't have phases but we
don't need four five and six so 17. then
it becomes then it just becomes
you know like the leprechaun series and
what the leprechaun in space
leprechaun's going to matter leprechaun
he would never go to harlem he go to
space and all the black people would
scatter they're terrified of that stuff
yeah
i mean david blaine street magic
you know what is crazy about all this is
we're not shut down right now
and i mean the whole country i mean
there's not a single jurisdiction in the
united states city county or otherwise
that is completely shut no every one of
them are already in a staged
opening right in the sense that there
are certain businesses and whether you
call them
essential or not but pet stores are open
why because you got to go to the
business you got to be able to get food
for your pets i understand that
there are a number of different
businesses that are still operating so
what we're talking about
is a change by degree so everyone who
goes if we open a single business the
whole america will die
right right doesn't make any sense we're
already open right now so all we're
talking about is making this change by
degree whether we need to do
two phases or four phases or we need to
approach it i mean the thing you've
talked about before since the very
beginning of this was
can we do some kind of spot quarantine
can we do this in a way that minimizes
the amount
of closure as opposed to just this
blanket close and wait we're doing it
already
and we're going to open it safely
quarantine old people sick people the
most vulnerable since that makes up
95 of the deaths and then allow everyone
else to not be thrust into a third world
economy seems to me
to be reasonable that's what we're
suggesting now i guarantee you anyone
out there
if they're complaining if you see people
on facebook anyone else this is this is
your
job okay people complaining about the
reopening show them
send them the link to the actual plan
the three-phase plan of reopening
right no one no one will have a problem
with it and by the way if they ever shut
down quick trip
i'm dead my diet my diet is nothing but
neuro bliss and taquitos
that is the hill that you would die on
isn't it you would break into the quick
trip
to get your stuff so but nobody's real
quick you made a great point that phase
plan go out there and look at it i
guarantee there's people watching right
now that have no idea it even exists
because no one is covering it in the
media
right right it is a phased approach
where we can go all right is phase one
going okay are we spiking our numbers
no let's go to phase two that is the
most reasonable thing and i am so i
gotta say
i'm just so disappointed in so many of
these conservative hosts out there who
have gone along with it because
listen we're not right about everything
but when it comes to this compared to
any we've been right about a lot we've
taken a very balanced approach and guess
what
when you're the only one who's right you
get no credit for it
because no one else wants to highlight
how wrong they are you have to lay off
half of fox news
so well they keep go back go back and
watch it just watch the show the people
arguing that we should stay closed are
the people who are
most of the time affected the least by
it right so we should take note of that
the people who had the least skin of the
game are the ones who are saying right
oh yeah yeah stay closed and see how
long we can run with this chicken you
know
right have this chicken can run without
its head yeah it's a setback
i thought you're gonna make that rails
off and you were like metaphor
[Laughter]
disaster of 1917 no wait 16 18.
yes he's going the wrong way uh no i
appreciate that's a good point like aoc
they're like i just don't show up to
work that's what aoc says
really terrible idea well you say that
after you get primaried you're crazy
broad so
you know you know i would love her not
to show up to work i do have to agree
with her on that point like
everyone has a choice but what you're
doing is you're taking away everyone
else's choice right you're telling them
that you're saying you don't know how to
exercise the kind of precautions that
are important
and this is what's really emblematic of
this from everything else is
it's the kind of paternalistic you can't
be trusted
to do something correct when you talk
about guns you talk about
uh raising a family you talk about all
these different things it comes down to
can you be trusted as an individual to
mostly make the right decision
have an agency to do it on your own or
do you need the government to dictate
every step you can take
every move you made and don't be
confused
don't be misled by me giving away twelve
hundred dollars to a truck driver who's
a fan of the show right if if you choose
to not show up to the work you'll be
fired immediately
that's right i'm here no apologies
unprepared i'm here i'm here i'm here
feels like you can talk to me or hr uh
here's also by the way what we're
talking about is trevor noah was
he said that we could reopen the economy
soon this isn't like it's foreign to him
the u.s economy may be able to start
reopening as early as next month
that's according to dr anthony fauci the
nation's top infectious disease
expert told cnn the economy could
gradually reopen in various parts of the
country
depending on the status of the pandemic
widespread testing availability
and sharp declines of people who are
seriously ill
we are hoping that at the end of the
month we could look around and say okay
is there any element here that we can
safely
and cautiously start pulling back on if
so
do it if not then just continue to
hunker down
straight from the freshly shaven
geppetto's mouth so
by the way he's not the only doctor in
the world for some this is the left they
just want to cling to dr fauci
uh dr burks um dr burks oh yeah she's
lovely wow
cutie and dr bird fetching lady who's i
don't want to say old but older than me
right beautiful women come in all shapes
and sizes and ages
primarily a dr burke's shape
um legal ages though she's been very
clear if i hey dr perks
i can be your joe biden you can be my
scratch and sniff that's all i'm talking
about
wow that's racist be my shirley temple
so
let's just just you know what let's just
say show dr berg sure doctor we have
told people
very clearly in the president guidelines
made it very clear
about the expectations of phase one and
remember phase one also included social
distancing in restaurants social
distancing
in every place that was entertainment
and keeping your own
individual social groups to less than
ten
i mean we've been very clear in the
guidelines and i think
it's up to the governors and mayors to
ensure that they're following the best
they can each of those
phases to make sure that both the public
is completely protected
hmm really
so uh she's talking again about a scale
let's let me give you an analogy here
let's say that you have the flu
okay um and this is important to note
because you can't only listen
to doctor's advice right you have to
listen to economists you have to listen
to people in the country people who
are truckers people who run small
businesses people who work in
maybe what you determine to be
non-essential services there has to be a
collective
discussion so let me kind of give you
let's say that you have the flu okay
just a really bad
flu some years right but you're also
about to go through a big business
merger or a busy season like for you
with
mine is typically in the fall right
right and uh you have a huge meeting on
monday that can determine the rest of
the year for your business you
absolutely positively cannot miss do you
ask your doctor whether you can attend
that meeting on monday you know he's
going to say no
right you absolutely know the the voice
of one doctor
is not the only voice it can't be the
only voice
and that's the danger with the logical
fallacy of appealing to authority it's
well dr fauci well i can find another
doc
right well and they're trying to say
something too i don't know if you saw in
the the little the bottom section there
i always mispronounce it so i'm not
going to pronounce it
if it was on screen while dr brooks was
talking i would not see anything
when we came back you you were like the
cartoon character with like heart eyes
i only have eyes and sinuses for her
right well they said it's uh
requirements they're not requirements
they're guidelines
yeah okay so you can't push people into
this category of like
not doing what is required these are
guidelines for your community you say
tomato
i say fascism so uh here's another
here's another uh clip from trevor noah
where this is another implication that
they're making on the left you can see
this on any mainstream website or reddit
politics oh my gosh i would just love to
see a coup
against not hurt anybody at reddit
politics but conservatives to migrate
there and just just make the voices
heard because it is amazing yeah that's
a horrible place
but it makes me want to again tow the
shotgun trigger just because i know it's
more effective than
a nine millimeter um and we're all about
efficiency here
so uh a little worried bill the
implications of protesters are all
conspiracy theorists
morons and of course the darwin award
they deserve to be wiped out by
covet now it would be a lot easier to
not take these protests seriously
if they were just being fueled by fox
news and internet conspiracy theories
the problem is that all of these morons
also have the support
of the [ __ ] in chief well luckily for
us sir david attenborough has agreed
to study these strange life forms to
help the rest of us
understand and here we see natural
selection in its purest
form a group of morons crowded together
spitting in each other's faces as they
demand the right
to get a haircut even for the
coronavirus
this is too easy all right here's the
thing
i like that one there's an insurance
concern so when i'm not looking can
someone stick a razor blade in my lunch
yeah yeah sure will that do the trick
thank you or that just irritate you
well i don't know no hopefully do
whatever it takes
okay it's looking the other direction
all right all right we'll have to it is
there is i we do have to go here's the
thing
we have senator ted cruz uh coming up
after this yeah um
there's this first off shows you what he
thinks of everyday americans right the
morons [ __ ] and chief and it also shows
you what he thinks of his attenborough
impression for god's sake man
that was bad that was bad there are so
many reasons that i can't stand trevor
noah and of course it combines the
elitism this smugness and he
by the way he is probably the least
familiar with flyover country because he
just
flew to new york in los angeles why
would he ever be in grand rapids
michigan why would he ever be
in el paso texas he has no exposure to
that so this is not a guy who should be
speaking to the average everyday
american good thing is look at his
ratings he's not
but there's unfunny there are unfunny
moments for some people for example
stephen colbert i don't think is always
funny but he comes by it honestly the
colbert report was very funny when he
used to do it
if you look at jimmy kimmel i don't
think he's always very funny but he
comes by and honestly the man show was
funny when he was there with adam
corolla right
if you look at david letterman you look
at conan o'brien uh all of these people
at some point even though i don't really
like jimmy fallon i understand that
college kids really liked his
impressions musically he's gifted i
understand
it but not all people trevor no it's
like he was
hit by an unfunny howitzer it is
remarkable to me
only trevor noah and samantha bee
they're smug they
hate you but more importantly when they
talk about americans
wanting to go back to work and they call
them morons
while you subsequently take a check for
a job that you do not do
as a comedian you don't do your job
trevor noah is everything wrong
with late night he's everything wrong
with politics and he's everything wrong
with this sort of pre-packaged you know
what they used to call bands like
sellouts yeah unfortunately like green
day they they committed this
this unbelievable unforgivable sin of
having an album that was successful
and i don't like them that's really
ridiculous you're a sellout
that being said trevor noah he is the
pre-packaged
corporate comedy that they're trying to
thrust upon the american public
that people don't want because they
don't think that he's going to tip over
any carts
think about this for a second you look
at the daily this is why it bothers me
he is the least qualified person for
that job
he is a diversity hire if you look at
the daily show it is just a who's who of
some of the best comedic actors and
comedians of our
we have stephen colbert steve carell rob
riggle
uh rob cordrey uh who else do we have uh
uh ed helms that's right
it's it's a it's a who's who's list and
then you have samantha b
and trevor noah and they are the only
ones to get their own
shows and you again when taking scale
into account
don't watch them it's everything wrong
with the entertainment industry and more
importantly
he's wrong your honor the south african
defense
is wrong we'll be back with trevor noah
not trevor no no
no make sure
home coffee tips with black rifle coffee
and mug club uh it's morning and we
decided to come in and dress up
we're going to show you today one of my
favorite methods
the aeropress the reason this is so
great is you kind of get a middle ground
between drip coffee
and espresso not really because it's
filtered but you can make a coffee
concentrate so first step i'm just going
to put the paper filter in here
put on the mug and the reason i'm doing
this you don't have to is just to
preheat
the vessel and the mug i'm going to
grind about 25 grams
of coffee
on the dot this grinder has a built-in
scale so i don't need to weigh it so
this is really simple with the aeropress
so what am i going to do there different
recipes what i like to do is fill it up
to about the number two or number three
mark
do what you like it's pretty tough to
make a crappy cup of coffee especially
if you're using the right temperature
and beans that are freshly roasted which
of course
you get at blackrifle.com crowder 20
off the promo coke rider when you're
using an aeropress is that a different
grind size
maybe from other you can do really fine
sizes if you want to do a short brew
time or you can do really coarse
and let it sit here's kind of a tip with
this if you want a stronger brew you
want it to brew longer you put that in
and just like a straw
you pull up a little bit that creates a
suction so right now that'll brew for as
long as i want it to brew you don't need
to brew it for that long though because
again i'm going to press
down gently to create pressure which
extracts of course along with heat
all of the compounds of the coffee so a
gentle press you kind of just use your
body weight
now you hear that once you start hearing
the hissing you stop
some people use a trash can i
have an assistant now see this is kind
of a concentrate there what most people
do if you want a big cup of coffee you
just do what they call bypass which is i
add water to it to make the size
of a cup of coffee that i want really
easy probably my favorite method
for making coffee at home so that floats
your boat
got anything that's like eight o'clock
some
something like something
[Music]
flat riflecoffee.com crowder uh enter in
promo code how do you get 20
off and it's important by the way to
note that they've donated i think over
20 000 bags of coffee with their buy a
bag give a bag campaign a veteran owned
it is a it is a lot of coffee and they
also just launched a new brand of
canned coffee that you can kind of add
to your you can get it online 200
milligrams of caffeine per can it's
coming from natural cup like i
as protein and i haven't had any they
haven't sent me any but
i hope you enjoy it uh
blackriflecoffee.com they have the balls
to sponsor the show and if you drink
coffee
just drink better coffee from a company
who gives a rat's ass
can't always get it watch this and more
at our other channel crowder bits
hey guys whisper blower again over the
past few weeks late night hosts have all
had to quarantine and do their shows
from home this is a very noble thing to
do in a time of public health crisis
such hold on
let's zoom in on that more
just as i thought it's the same wall
they thought we wouldn't notice but this
smoking gun tipped me off it will
disappear
we remember that we're not goldfish
while trump has the memory of a goldfish
who smokes weed do they
really expect us to believe that with
multi-million dollar budgets and
hundreds of writers that they're just
this
unoriginal no they haven't been
quarantined at all
they've been forming a secret cabal
aimed to destroy late night comedy with
terrible writing and apathetic
production value
and they hold all their meetings in a
rented bedroom of the mark twain house
thanks for watching guys i'm just gonna
plug my gofundme here again
uh i just signed the lease on a new
apartment after getting that mcn deal
but it turned out to be a bit of a scam
[Music]
i lost my whole life savings
what's the blower health
[Music]
that was me doing the uh like i said the
orchestra pit i went to a symphony uh
christmas i think he's making it up oh
yeah i don't believe him for a second
someone's like oh that's a g i meant f
yeah i don't believe it it's an art you
just don't understand it uh yeah you
know kind of like uh most post-modern
art only i guess it's not postmodern
all right uh speaking of classics our
next guest i don't know
oh yeah but i am tired uh you can follow
him
on the twitter at ted cruz of course
he's a senator i don't think he
you know i know he hosts a podcast now
from where it's like is it called the
verdict or something with ted cruz
senator cruz
you've entered into the podcast space
well stephen i'm i'm doing what i can to
compete in your arena
and and i gotta say though when you open
your show with those dance moves nobody
told me dancing would be involved in
this
that that uh you you may have some
natural advantages
uh over me in that arena i do namely a
lack of self-respect
but this isn't a podcast this is a late
night show
every and i will say every tom dick and
harry has a podcast so how are you going
to differentiate yourself aside from
obviously being like a sitting senator
and
the wonderful beard yes it's very great
well you know i
when we launched it we launched uh
verdict
during impeachment and we did it every
night right after the trial we'd go and
film it live and it
you know it never existed i remember my
team and we the first day we went on we
said all right what would be success and
we were saying well
if we can get into the top 100 that
would be great we ended up skyrocketing
to being the number one ranked podcast
in the world
and and we we have had uh
enormous enthusiasm people signing up uh
both both uh for the podcast download
but also on youtube you know i know
youtube you and youtube have gone round
and round and i've engaged in those
battles
um but but they haven't as of yet uh
banned my podcast from youtube so so i
may not be doing it right stephen i may
ask for some of your advice on that
right no they just fact check you by
redirecting
folks to nancy pelosi so that's what and
i don't know if in your podcast if you
act
like an idiot like i i just spilled
water on my shirt
and on my computer we're gonna have to
replace all that okay and senator cruz
you guys couldn't see senator cruz was
playing it off like a gentleman he
didn't point out like are you an idiot
oh yeah are you a simpleton did you just
spill water on your shirt you
[ __ ] i'm a sitting senator um
so there's well i'm glad to hear that
you are doing well we need more people
out there as far as youtube you know
it's it's not so much a give and take
it's really more like um
like ali chuck webner i just i take
pride in making it to the 14th round and
then of course they'll ban me
um before we move on you were just
talking about those are air pods that
you're wearing right now but they're not
the air pod
pros you said you don't like those for
some weird reason yeah no so it's the
it's the simple it's the bottom of the
line version of the airpods so it's this
it's the cheapest one and i don't know
the airpod pros to be honest i haven't
tried them but i didn't like how they
look like they stick
deep in your ear and i sort of i like
how these ones fit i'm comfortable with
these and so i don't really
didn't really want to jam the things
deep in my ear and these work fine you
make that sound far less
uh uh pleasant than it is it's it's not
that big of an ordeal but that being
said
those don't fit in my ear the original
one they would just fall out i have huge
ears and then the new airpod pros
they come with three different sizes and
they do like an air suction test or it
tells you you have the right size i
tried the biggest size
and it just said what's wrong with you
what is it it's a customer have you
tried
maybe should go to 23andme and see
what's wrong with your genetic
lineage because my ear canals are so big
nothing fits um all right so listen
senator cruz i'm glad that you're
wearing uh you're wearing the standard
ones we don't want to
we don't want to hear about any hearing
damage what is going on
right now with china
i'm not a big fan uh of what's been
going on with this whole pandemic in the
world health organization and
i know you've been outspoken with this
seems like more people now are coming
around for the longest time we were kind
of the lone
lone voice in the wilderness um what do
people need to know
and how should the american government
take what stance should be taken right
now
well listen china is a bad player the
communist government of china has been
responsible for
millions of deaths murders tortures they
have they have over a million of their
own citizens uyghurs in concentration
camps
right now they engage in censorship
surveillance
oppression uh they engage in global
espionage
they for a long time i had been
advocating that that the position that
that china
is the single greatest geopolitical
threat to the united states over the
next century
uh they are investing massively billions
in their military
and and they rely on intellectual
property theft
as a strategy from the government the
history of mankind that has never
happened we've had thieves we've had
pirates
right but never a nation-state with
trillions of dollars of resources
investing and stealing stealing military
hardware stealing
uh commercial hardware stealing medical
innovations
and you know we just saw the
consequences
uh of their censorship regime we've
always thought of their censorship as a
human rights issue but the cover-up that
they
engaged in with this coronavirus
outbreak illustrates that their
censorship is not just a human rights
issue
it is a national security issue and a
global health issue
because in a very real sense china bears
responsibility
for the over 170 000 people who have
died
due to coved 19 and the trillions of
dollars
of economic value that's been destroyed
i think it's a very good
way to put it's very important that
people realize as a basis of how they do
commerce intellectual
uh property theft and you know as a
libertarian you can get into sort of
this idea of intellectual property
sometimes violates real property rights
where if i say hold on a ham sandwich
and i coin it and it's like well i have
ham and bread i can't put it into a ham
sandwich
that being said with chyna you know my
wife used to run she was a vp of a
contract furniture company
at a big expo called neocon in chicago
every year she was assigned for two
years that she was working her way up
just to make sure that um specifically
people from from chinese companies and
vendors didn't come in take pictures of
their chairs to rip them off because
they would do all of
this work they would have them you know
test it up this is tested up to like 700
pounds
and initially i told that story and
people said that's racist she said no no
it's not
it's they don't think it's wrong she
said you have to explain to them no no
you can't do this
and sometimes people were very surprised
apply that to a global
health pandemic or apply that to um yeah
and even more unfortunately god you know
youtube and google with dragonfly
they're creating a search engine to
to kowtow to these people it sends
shivers down my spine
look big tech and and much of big
business in america and much of the
mainstream media in america
they're terrified of china because china
represents big bucks it represents
dollars they want
access to the chinese market you know
just yesterday
youtube announced that they were going
to pull down anything
on their site that was contrary to the
recommendations of the world health
organization the world health
organization
is a chinese puppet that has echoed
the the communist propaganda from china
in the midst of the coronavirus pandemic
in
january in late january the world health
organization
tweeted out that there's no evidence of
human to human transmission
of the corona virus and and china is
doing a great job
uh dealing with it right at the time
china was covering it up and hiding it
and helping contribute
to this global pandemic and and
the the willingness to sell out for the
almighty dollar
um i think is really really dangerous
when it comes to china they
use their economic might yeah hollywood
is terrified own so hollywood censors
them out
out of movies right yeah they changed
red dawn from
what did they change it from china to
korea which wasn't really believable
like come on speaking of
chinese look puppet looking i know north
korea not chinese but you know you come
on the guy looks like a puppet
let's be honest but people saw team
america if you flip through the channels
really quickly you're tired in your
hotel room and it's on hbo
you think it's that you think it's a
biopic um yeah
i think team america is is one of the
greatest movies ever made
it absolutely it is yeah absolutely they
managed to piss
everybody off on the right and left and
i was going none of you guys get this
it makes fun of everybody and look it
makes fun of conservatives i can deal
with that look at you i mean if you're
laughing makes fun of everybody
i will say though every third word is a
profanity yeah
and and heidi and i made the mistake of
bringing a team america dvd
on vacation with her parents and and i
sort of
was forgetting thinking it was a little
more family friendly
i would just say the look from your
mother-in-law when you're playing a
50-second
f-bomb with puppets the puppet secrets
how do you forget that that makes me
question are you going the way of biden
i mean that's not even a short-term
memory thing and it's
you're being very by the way generous
and saying f-bombs no no
it's that it's used as a descriptor
well it's um hey
hey freedom isn't free it's a bucco 5.
yes sir yes sir
and i think you just gained more fans
with that
than all of your number one podcasts
combined people now say oh ted cruz
senator ted cruz gets it um let me ask
you this with chyna
i talked about this so we've been
covering this for a very long time and
i will say this i never walked it back i
thought early on i said listen this
could get bad
i don't think it's as bad as people are
making it out to be i see a lot of
people walking some of their doomsday
predictions back but we always focused
on china
when we ran the video of the who
representative uh who
flat out denied or flat-out refused to
answer the question regarding taiwan
and then hung up the skype call it maybe
had a few hundred plays at that point
nobody else was covering it of course
youtube redirected it to something else
learn more about kovid19
it is remarkable to me where these when
you have leftists who talk about darfur
and they talk about these human rights
abuses across the world
but right now when there's something
that we could do about it we're we're in
a position
where there's an international dynamic
where we could do something and we're in
a position of power
where the global community could support
us not a peep
i don't well i do get it but i don't
maybe you can shed some some light on it
for me so i don't get it wrong
so look the corruption that we see with
the media is profound let's take okay so
last fall last october
uh i i did an asia trip and i traveled
to
pearl harbor japan taiwan
india hong kong and it was designed to
really be a friends and allies to
be all around china yes i had a lot of
[ __ ] yes yes
you had my brother went to india he's
like i gotta space these out i gotta do
this
and he still came back and was sick for
two weeks
so i did get to film in india outside
the ministry of defense
on my phone i filmed there was just this
this whole
herd or flock of monkeys i don't know
what do you call a group of monkeys is
it a
pride as lions i don't know what i'm
gonna let you die out on this vine here
along with your school of monkeys
i think it's a i think it's a barrel
senator cruz yeah i i i don't know but
it was a crap ton among them
okay they were running around at plague
and it was like baby monkeys that i
filmed it all and sent it to my girls
the only part of the trip they thought
was cool
was like the monkeys that were playing
right next to the ministry of defense
sure um but the whole
course of that trip okay okay that would
be my
okay who's yelling at your home like
national tv
caroline okay she just ran away my 12
year old said she thought the monkeys
were stupid so sorry about that well you
know what you're
your daughter sounds very judgmental and
i don't know that i appreciate that on
this program we don't tolerate that kind
of
gender species discrimination uh but let
me let me redirect since i know we both
got distracted here
would it be at all feasible to say you
know what you cost these uh hundreds of
thousands of lives
china you lied about it there's some
debt here we're gonna renegotiate or you
know what
you're not gonna see a penny until you
sort this out is that something that's
within our power to do because i know
that
a lot of the intellectual elites have
said that's outside the realm of
possibility to just use it as a
bargaining chip
look i think that will be a major topic
of discussion i think the first thing we
need to have is just accountability we
need to know what happened we need to
document
so for example the origins of the
pandemic we now know that there were not
one but
two chinese labs controlled by the
chinese government
in wuhan within miles of where the
outbreak occurred
that not only were researching
coronaviruses they were researching
coronaviruses derived from bats and they
had live population of bats
they were researching we know that there
were serious questions about the
security protocols
at these labs including multiple state
department wires before the pandemic
raising questions about the security and
saying this could lead to a global
pandemic
there needs to be serious inquiry did
this
virus escape accidentally from one of
those chinese labs
china refuses to answer that they don't
want to answer that
they will not answer the simple question
were you studying the navel coronavirus
this particular coronavirus
at that lab and did it accidentally
escape and and
the media point we were making before so
i've been raising these questions for
for about six weeks now early march is
when i started raising these questions
the media reacted like like they lit
their hair
on fire and they said you're a crazy
tinfoil hat wearing conspiracy theorist
which is actually what they call us any
other day too sure that roof is not
really different
yeah but the washington post had this
big reputation that they ran i think
early march if i remember right
where they said people pointing to these
labs
are crazy conspiracy theorists why
because the genetic makeup of the virus
does not suggest it was created in a lab
but occurred naturally
now one of the real tells when someone
is trying to deceive you
is they work for them when they answer a
different well there is that yeah
but they answer a different question
than you asked
no one is arguing that this was created
in a lab
what what the the circumstantial
evidence suggests
is that this was being studied in a lab
it may well have been naturally
occurring
but that it was being studied in a lab
and they did such a half-assed job
that it escaped and and
that view now there's more and more
evidence to support it there needs to be
real accountability we know
china covered it up we know they
punished they silenced
uh the whistleblowers that try to draw
attention to it
but once we have accountability in terms
of understanding what they did then i
think there will be a real global
reassessment
of what the consequences will be for the
deaths and the trillions of dollars of
economic value
that china bears direct responsibility
for right hey really quickly web
extended
and there we go uh usually this would be
behind the paywall but because we're
doing free mug club month mug club
quarantine let me ask you this what
we're talking about reassessing
why is there why was there any american
funding
going to a lab in wuhan these are all i
don't understand that
um i i know that you don't agree with it
but it is remarkable to me where we sort
of talk about the legitimate purview of
government and you're sort of more of a
libertarian conservative like i am
that's where i fall in the political
compass test which is useless but
you know i cite it when it's convenient
for me it's so
far outside of the purview of the
legitimate role of government
how many steps of screw-ups does it take
for us to find that we are funding a lab
that could be creating communicable
communicable deadly diseases for years
to come
well sadly it is hopeless naivete and
driven by ideology listen there is a
perfectly legitimate role for government
to research pandemics and how to stop
them what the cdc
does we need to be prepared to keep us
safe the stupid part
is that we were sending taxpayer funding
to the wuhan lab to the lab in china
that that that had shoddy security
measures
and whose government the chinese
communists
are not our friends they are our enemies
and and and this is look it's the same
naivete that led the obama
administration
to send a hundred billion dollars to the
ayatollah khamenei
who chants death to america don't give
millions of dollars or billions of
dollars to people who want to kill you
that principle is true the same
principle is true don't get don't give
money to a chinese lab um
they're not our friends and and we
shouldn't be giving a penny to china
yeah
and it was foolish ideological naivete
that caused the obama administration to
stand that money open and let's be clear
this is this wasn't partnering with
privatized chinese labs this wasn't the
wuhan equivalent of quest
or labcorp right that doesn't exist
there and because of
i know that you feel this way because of
my empathy for the chinese people
i have nothing but disdain for the
communist chinese government and what i
would hate to see is them build up a
military
and forcibly enlist people for this god
forbid it ever leads to some kind of a
global
conflict or catastrophe because guess
what there's a huge portion of the
chinese people right now
who are just as pissed off as we are
only they don't have a voice and guess
what
they have no hope of a voice when they
look at the american media trying to
silence american senators and hosts do
you have any idea i mean i know you have
an idea but for people do you have any
idea how demoralizing that has to be for
a chinese citizen right now to go hey i
want to speak up i want to earn freedom
oh wait a second
they're fact checking senator ted cruz
for saying this
and they're redirecting from stephen
crowder's show i better be quiet now
but let you're right but let me give you
some real encouragement
which is freedom is powerful
you know some years ago i sat down with
the town sherenski the famed soviet
dissident he and i sat down in jerusalem
and he described how when he was in a
soviet gulag
they would pass from cell to cell notes
saying did you hear what reagan said
referring to the soviet union as an evil
empire
saying marxism leninism will end up on
the ash heap of history
saying mr gorbachev tear down this wall
those
words that there is power and
tyrannies communist tyrannies are
terrified of truth
let me point to an example i i think it
is very valuable to highlight dissidents
it's one of the things i try to do often
right you're right there are heroic
dissidents in china
standing up for freedom against their
oppressive government one of them was
liu xiaobo
luja about nobel peace laureate spoke up
for democracy was imprisoned
and won the nobel peace prize for
speaking up against the chinese
communist government
um i actually took a page um out of
reagan's
book i introduced legislation to rename
the street in front of the chinese
embassy
in dc lujabel plaza oh that sounds nice
reagan
reagan did that during the cold war he
renamed the street in front of the
soviet embassy sakura plaza after sakura
the soviet distance um
i tried to get it passed in the senate
and a democrat dianne feinstein objected
she and i argued back and forth on the
senate floor repeatedly dianne feinstein
said
but but but this will irritate the
chinese government to which i responded
yesterday and that is the perfect do you
have to finish the story i just i just
threw up in my mouth a little senator
cruz
you said you were going to give me hope
speak words of comfort to me mr cruz
so you will like the end of the story
which is that
which is that this is during the obama
administration i placed a hold on every
nominee to the state department the
obama administration freaked out said
how can we get you to lift the hold i
said it's very simple pass my
legislation
get feinstein to withdraw her objection
they did my legislation passed the
senate unanimously 100 to nothing
and then i lifted the hold fast forward
a couple of years later
luzhabo passes away his widow lucia
is still in china uh trump is the new
president rex tillerson's the secretary
of state i'm having breakfast with rex
tillerson
tillerson told me and talking to china
they raised among their top three
priorities
was don't let this legislation pass it
already passed the senate
stop cruz's legislation because it
terrified them right
and i told rex at the time i said listen
use me as the bad guy
tell china we're gonna pass this unless
they release lucia
they did they released her and let her
out that's how scared they are of truth
so keep speaking the truth what what you
say what i
say what the dissidents say it terrifies
she and then and and the chinese
dictators i don't know if what i say so
much terrifies them as much as they just
want to beat my ass but they laugh
while punching me uh so it's a useful
skill
uh speaking of which what am i gonna be
making an appearance on your uh uh
podcast there senator cruz
oh uh we'll make it happen i refuse the
invitation
i will never do it uh i just wanted to
put one over on a senator
uh very strong very very strong
i wanted to ask you about the
immigration ban but you know what um i
just want to sit
but stephen stephen i just want to be
clear as a result of that action just
remember i know where your underground
bunker is and
and the black helicopters circling and
the storm troopers pulling out
and and locking the doors i have nothing
to do with that yeah well i can imagine
you know it's tough to know because
every now and then it sounds like a
tugboat is going past this studio
we picked an area that was away from
airports and then they started running a
train
that like what is this he just started
running this is it the polar express you
stopped like
and now we found out there's a track so
i wouldn't be able to hear him coming
so that's another one for you senator
cruz and i wanted to talk about the
immigration ban but you know what i'm
really glad to hear you speak
uh out about china i've been following
you you've been an inspiration and i
hope
that i know they i know they don't and
unfortunately you know we thought this
would be the silver lining with new
media because we know that chinese media
will
never allow those dissidents or never
allow their citizens to see these kinds
of conversations on television
and unfortunately now we're running into
the same roadblocks with big tech so i
appreciate your fight there as well
senator ted cruz thank you brother i
know you're busy keep up the good fight
we'll talk with you soon
excellent take care god bless we're
gonna wrap this up
[Music]
tonight on nbc hello everyone
and welcome to late night from
my hallway seth catches up with the news
smoke this it'll make the pain stop or
it won't there's no science behind that
and a special guest hello
there you go
[Music]
i stepped
[Music]
even for me that was too much
do you exclusively shop in dumpsters
you do don't you
you look like a homeless man's ass rag
a look only a raccoon would love is this
what a stroke is
pure unadulterated disappointment
personified in clothing
but lucky for you i have a solution
ladderwithcrowdershop.com
now that's what i'm talking about you'll
be beating the women away with a stick
looking that good
beguile your potential mates with your
sheer masculinity
become the envy of all your friends
while showing off
those legs heck you're downright rugged
unfortunately for you it doesn't correct
crippling anxiety
cover your bits and tackle with silky
smooth ranger panties
at lotterycrowdershop.com
[Music]
there was a drowning dance where i
realized i was wearing a white shirt
uh and i didn't i did you can't swim in
a white shirt i don't want to
end up like vienna immodest yeah it's
not common bachelor
i am so sad that i know that my wife
i only and i only remember her because
she was one husband and she was like
miss
uh miss wet t-shirt in my hand
that's an actual prize and how horrible
must the fourth place
finisher feel for that like you you were
a wet t-shirt in miami and you were good
but you didn't even meddle good not that
good
uh thank you to senator ted cruz and
tomorrow we have uh representative dan
crenshaw on the show good morning mug
club um
and we appreciate you guys tuning in
there's been a lot of people and we've
gotten a lot of feedback
and of course promo code quarantine 30
off this is still
mug club quarantine and it ends on
thursday which is i'm not gonna lie it's
been a lot of work for uh quite a few
folks here um
i've been uh you know i've been i've
talked with you guys before the show
it's um
you know when i get tired i'm like oh
i'm tired something i'm not going to do
something but i'm always concerned about
doing it well
right you know so sometimes i'll get to
the point where i tape in the morning
and then we have to work and take
sketches and write all day and i'm like
oh my gosh we can do this show at night
but
i just don't want you know i don't want
to sound like joe biden yeah yeah
not a good look no it's different like
if you're tired you're in an office job
you can edit you can hide but
hi where am i going to go i would go
under the desk you're like oh he's on
the spectrum
which i am sensory deprivation so i have
been pretty tired
um the show is a lot of work and i wanna
you know i uh
there is a lot that bothers me about
this this pandemic right now what really
bothers me
is people saying this is a crisis that
we've never known that we've never seen
in our lifetime well let me tell you
something there are people out there who
are going through crap before this
and who have been going through crap
during this that is
far more severe and talk about tone deaf
you know i didn't want to talk about
this and my wife and i weren't going to
until she felt comfortable with
this but i have been tight there's been
something kind of going on some people
have noticed that maybe i feel a little
tired i get a little bit testy um
yeah uh to to explain it uh
i was very my wife and i have been
trying to become
parents for a long time and
i was very happy that i thought i was
going to be a father
until i i wasn't now listen people have
it worse than that right this
is not all that uncommon uh but uh yeah
is semi-devastating i would say
and the reason for this too and this is
something that i think a lot of
feminists miss because
all men if you've ever had a pregnant
wife have you ever been through
something like a miscarriage
you just want to serve as best you can
and you don't necessarily know
how you just know this is something that
obviously they are feeling more
intensely
and you feel things really intensely but
but you can't show it and that's kind of
what i was talking about i mentioned it
as a joke that was a bit veiled
last week where i talked with sort of a
marriage counselor after this which is
i encourage people to do where i said
you know men sort of we don't really
want to sit there and cry
in front of our wives because we don't
want them to feel that they lack
the stability or someone to lean on and
so it's you're like a dog you go off
into the woods to die
she thought that was kind of funny and i
still think yeah you know i'm the dog
who goes off into the woods to die
i'm a dog um but let me tell you this
what the roller coaster was and why
coronavirus was i got to tell you
it's still at the bottom of my list of
priorities right now
upon hearing you know weeks ago that
okay i was going to finally be a dad um
i don't know if anyone else has
experienced this but i was like oh wow
immediately like crippling fear set in i
was like oh my god okay what do i need
to do we have to redo the house
well we have to turn this up we have to
turn the office into a baby room and
okay we got to make sure well now we
gotta get a fence for the pool and we
got to make sure that okay that you get
a book for betty and
i think that when this hat you know
often women are just thinking about how
they feel and and we're sort of thinking
about what we need to do
this is my experience anyway and uh
then when the news
was delivered about not about about it
not
about a miscarriage let's just call what
it is about a miscarriage um
it really wasn't fear it was it was uh
it was it was sadness
and i think sometimes and i think we
confuse fear with negative emotions
sometimes not that sad is always a
negative emotion but sometimes
fear sets in because of something that
matters sometimes
you're fearful because you don't want to
lose something that brings you so much
joy something that is so important to
you
and that's why i think that fear is
pretty damn close to
not only intelligence but emotional
intelligence
eq um and one thing the reason that i
talk about this and and i often talk
about these things i've talked about my
struggles in the past with
with sort of mental health issues and
struggling with with uh depressionist
because i know that there are a lot of
people out there listening and it
doesn't solve anything i'm not one of
those celebrities who
first off i'm not a celebrity but i'm
not one of those people who when a
celebrity
dies everyone comes out and goes oh i've
struggled with this as well like heath
ledger died and everyone came out
all right struggle with the pressure
where were you when that wasn't in the
tabloids where were you when that wasn't
in the headlines and people were looking
for someone to relate to
and so i've tried to be transparent with
those things so that you
out there don't have to suffer uh
alone and that's what i'm doing
right now i'm sure that a lot of people
out there it's not all that uncommon
um have gone through this and i don't
want you to feel
like you're suffering food alone but let
me i'm also doing this a little bit
selfishly
um i'd like to you know what i would
like to see people who've been
through this same scenario comment below
let me let me know what it was so i'm
not complaining about that but i'm not
gonna lie it makes it pretty tough and i
have to have my wife
stay away from the computer and everyone
is usually right when they talk about
the nightmare that is the comment
section
okay but i'm gonna i'm just gonna be a
little vulnerable here and
and do this and trust uh trust that
humanity has a little bit
more to offer by pointing them to the
comment section below
i wanna see what you have to say about
this i wanna see what people out there
have been through and i want to see you
supporting each other because
we have all of these tools and i think
it slipped through our fingers we
thought social media this
online we're going to be more connected
than ever and instead it just became
about crapping on each other and i
didn't believe me the irony is not lost
on me that i just took a big steaming
dump on trevor noah that being said he
has a national platform we're not
exactly punching down
uh and i certainly wouldn't consider uh
bullying him in the comments section
namely i don't know that he knows how to
read not a racial thing it's a dumb
thing um
so this is what really bothers me with
the coronavis comment below with the
coronavirus virtue signaling because
when i tell you this and while everyone
else has scaled back we've really tried
to scale up two shows a day right
because we want to serve
you we're not nurses we're not doctors
we thought people are quarantined people
are isolated
they're yearning for connection for
content i know i've been
uh it's been a grueling couple of weeks
two shows
it's hard really hard and this isn't
just a podcast where we talking to a
microphone and caller show okay
i hope that that seeing the late night
hosts broadcasting from home
has highlighted just how much work this
entire team puts into the show
yeah you see me hosting and you see
people in this room and yeah okay you
see the you see the fruits of our
writing maybe you see some jokes maybe
you see a photoshop
but you don't necessarily understand how
much work always goes from people who
you never get to see or occasionally see
on a security camera if it's brendan
when colbert is broadcasting from his
home with just a few crappy punch lines
and maybe a photo still
and he still has five to ten times the
staff of anyone working
here right now and that same week you
can look at those same weeks look at
stephen colbert look at kimmel look at
trevor no look at samantha we've done
massive parodies sketches original
content twice the volume of shows
this not myself and i wouldn't be able
to do it without them you know how you
know do you know how you know that
go back and watch this show watch my
youtube channel before
this team now creatively sure
impressions
sure jokes sure was i able to go out and
do hidden camera stuff
yeah but it was maybe once a week once a
month
the volume of content and the quality of
content that you see this isn't me
bragging on myself
wouldn't be able to do it without this
remarkable
outfit and you know what they're never
gonna you'll never hear us say that
we're the number one show with a bullet
in this space
that when you add up all the avenues
where people consume this that you know
everyone else is competing for a distant
second because we like to focus on the
work
but that's the truth that is absolutely
the truth and i don't say for myself i
say for what they've done they are the
ones who helped make this number one
because i've been around for a while and
i wasn't even number 51.
so when i see reporters and activists on
social media just
wailing like kim jong-il died and they
deserve a razzy
because of this pandemic when they
haven't lost their business
they haven't lost their jobs many of
them don't have employees
at all to support let alone families to
support they didn't even get the
sniffles and they say this is the worst
episode in our history however when we
regain hope really
really what have you lost
what if specifically because of covid19
what have you
lost and i'll tell you this you can look
at the timeline of covid19
what i've lost would i'll never get back
has nothing to do
with a virus that is increasingly
seeming like having the mortality rate
of the flu
has nothing to do with that you know
what i lost i lost not being able to
know the things i thought about the na
what am i going to name
him or her is going to be look like me
or more like more like my wife
be shy or will he be outgoing is he
going to seem like audio aids kid who's
great and i really love hanging out with
him how is he going to interact with
betty what are his dreams and hopes
going to be
when am i going to see his personality
develop never get to know that that is i
want to be really clear about this okay
this isn't me bitching but this is also
as we talk about that is a life
lost that is a life loss that i will
never get to know
and this is really messed up but i was
talking with someone about this
on the team and women understand that i
have just gone into my hole
with this and tried to be as supportive
as i can and then at one point cry like
a
[ __ ] in the car listening to james
taylor which thankfully no one will ever
see
except the nsa um
[ __ ] me i'm uncomfortable in talk with
talking about this stuff
uh all right what was i saying what was
i saying before this occur like it
oh i was talking with someone on the
team
and women might not ever the my body my
choice that's absolutely true okay i
understand it i understand that there's
something that my wife is going through
that i'll never know but there is
also and men please tell me again in the
comments section if you've
been through this with a miscarriage
i've been trying not i'm just going to
call it what it is
there's a almost i don't want to use the
word jealousy but that's where it is
when
you have all of these hopes and dreams
and this idea of what your
child could or or maybe won't be
and it gets taken away from you and
you're almost sort of jealous that at
least your
your wife was able to have a connection
with that life that you're
you're never going to get to have that's
tough and it's tough to say
if you say it you sound like you're
being an inconsiderate prick
i don't mean to be but i want to know if
that's something that i'm that i suffer
alone with
i want to know if that's something other
people out there have have felt because
we usually don't talk about this and
certainly men don't really talk about it
they go
yeah it's a tough racket no it's a
really tough record and so when i see
people in the media right now acting
like all is lost when they personally
have lost
nothing and they don't they just
absolutely belittle the people who've
experienced
real loss in this pandemic
this this whole charade from the media
not saying the virus is a hoax but the
blowing it out of proportion
and using it as a political weapon it's
belittled real loss
it's belittled when people experience
real loss because i'll tell you the
virus has made it very hard for us to
scale up
a lot of work made it hard to keep work
afloat period it's made
every single day for people here one big
stub stutter step just oh
we gotta oh okay we gotta snow we gotta
do this show that's right we have we
have another show i don't get to relax
we have to be up at 4am to prepare for
the next show but compared to what
my wife and i have been going through it
is nothing it is
nothing it's a walk in the caution taped
off park
and you know what we all have an empathy
meter this is a thing that people don't
want to talk about we all have a
set empathy meter and at a certain point
it runs out
and i want my heart to be open to the
people who need it
and we can't keep running everyone's
empathy meter down to nothing
without refilling it back up with some
validation and that's
what is happening right now with this
virus what you are doing
is draining people of their empathy
because at a certain point
they have nothing left to give
especially when you aren't empathizing
with them and they don't know how
they're going to put food
on the table or especially when you talk
about oh my god i can't believe that
there's a disease out there
a virus that could have a death rate of
0.2 percent when there are people out
there
who are going through miscarriages who
have parents with early onset dementia
who have cancer running in the family
who maybe just had to hold their dog in
their arms while they put them down
people are experiencing
real loss and so when we go into 2020
this was the strategy from the left they
wanted you to be
they wanted to appear empathetic and
they wanted you to remember
all of this loss that they were hoping
and praying for when you actually look
at their
statements it's very clear what the
motivation was i'm not attributing
motive they said that if you watch cnn
guess what i want you to remember it too
i want you to remember
all of this and i want you to remember
what you lost versus what you were told
would be lost
and the real losses that you've had in
your life all along the way i hope to
see you in the comment section and uh
regain some some faith in humanity you
guys are usually pretty good you do a
good job all right i'll see you tomorrow
good morning
[Music]